- On voit bien la position
de notre implant.
vers le bas. Très bien,
une belle baisse de pressi de p.
- Le glaucome est l'une des plus
graves maladies de l'oeil causée
liquide qui provoque une forte
pressinerf optique.
C'est un processus lent, qui
touche 2 % des plus de 40 ans,g,
et qui peut provoquer
cité totale.
Jean-Pierre Blais en souffre
depuis une quarantaine d'années.
- Ma mère, lorsqu'elle
est décédée, était aveugle
dû au glaucome. Ma soeur,
est presque aveugle elle aussi.
- Aujourd'hui, ses deux yeux
sont touchés, surtout le gauchee
de lire, je suis pas capable
de rien écouter à la télé
ou rien de ça. Quand on n'a pasr
la tête pour voir quelqu'un.
- Le glaucome est incurable.
Mais aujourd'hui, on peutou mêmr
compl sa progression.ment, M. Bé
ticiper à une première
québécoise au CHUM, à Montréal e
t de 8 millimètres
de longueur dans son oeil droitM
- En gros, le but, c'est debaisl
et aveant-làant-làant-làant-làa,
on crée une bulle de filtration
sous l
la partie de peau par-dessus
la pare de l'oeil, et
ça crée cette bulle qui permet
le dra
et de baisser la pression.
plant est si petit
que l'ouverture du conduit
d'un cil humain. Il faut
des doigts de fée pour
l'insérer au bon endroit,
dans la bonne position,
- On place l'implant de sorte
qu'il soit dans une zone o
est-ce qu'il va pouvoir avoir
une bonne filtration de liquide,
de chances de cicatriser.
Et on doit s'ass
qu'il n'est pas bloqué parce que
comme il est tout petit, il y a
- La chirurgie a duré
à peure et
M. Blais a récupéré rapidement.
Une semaine plus tard,
- La technologie fait
s incroyabs incroyabs incroyabs,
puis je suis bien heureux
d'en profiter dans le momeoiroir
à l'usage si cette technologie
tient ses promesses.
- Là, on va
les prochaines années, avec
l'évolution de lavec l'évolutioe
chirurgicale, àint
on est capable d'utiliser
ces imet prévenir le glaucome
de conprogresserprogresserprogr.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada,